the clark county school district has
delayed discussions
on its hybrid learning model that
decision came during a board meeting
last night
as kate houston reports some students
and teachers feel a sense of relief
students and teachers are weighing in as
the clark county school district delays
its decision on a hybrid learning plan
i feel as though it's the best decision
for them to take right now in the moment
that we're in
just so they don't make a decision we
can later on regret making
the delay comes after governor sissel
sisilak's suggestion to stay at home as
cases of kovit 19
continue to climb teacher jamie anderson
says she's relieved adding they should
see how the next couple of weeks play
out before making a determination
really focus on what's going to be best
for the students in the long run
and if going back is going to be really
in the in the best interest of the
students for this school year
this delay now gives the clark county
school district time to fine tune its
plan
during a meeting friday superintendent
dr jesus jarrah
says there needs to be a standardized
distance learning curriculum across the
district
right now some students are getting it
through canvas and other platforms
curriculum our families from what i'm
hearing are frustrated so that's one of
the things that we're
we're going to really bring back into
the plan
for when we come back to school while
there's no target date to get students
back in the classroom
dr jarrah wants to bring the hybrid
learning plan back to the board in
december
in order to get everyone back in the
classroom though he wants to see a
downward trend in covet 19 cases
adding the safety of families and
district employees is his top priority
kate houston 8 news now dr jarrah also
spent some time talking about mental
health saying 11 students have died by
suicide this school year this week a
pilot program kicked off at nearly a
dozen schools
focusing on mental health resources that
program will eventually be expanded to
all schools and we've also heard from
you the
people that really do want to get their
kids back into school so we've heard
your representation as well